[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive du
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux ont repris le
championnat de première division ce
week-end dans leur stade jean maréchal
et ils ont débuté par deux victoires
face aux pas réussi grâce à leur
nouvelle recrue venue du venezuela
fuller franck lopez
tous les détails dans ce set 8 sports
boxe dans le championnat wba
super-moyens l'ylang courtois d'ilham
houmadi s'est incliné aux points le
vendredi 30 mars à levallois face à
nadjib mohammedi à l'unanimité des trois
juges une défaite qui pourrait le priver
d'un titre mondial nous leur seconde en
quelques instants
rugby à le sky s'est imposé ce week-end
contre ministère finance sur le score de
29 à 14
une victoire qui leur permet de se
maintenir de justesse en division
honneur le résumé du match sera sue dans
quelques instants
coup de projecteur à présent sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du
week-end dans le département
[Musique]
je le disais à dans les titres en
baseball et cougar de montigny le
bretonneux ont repris à la saison de
division 1 ce dimanche avec la réception
du paris uc au stade jean maréchal
lésigny menton emporté de justesse 1 0
et 5 à 4 un retour sur ces matches
d'ouverture des images de nicolas landry
avantage de romain russe fini c'était la
rentrée pour les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux dans leur stade jean maréchal
lésigny montain recevait le paris uc
pour leur premier match de la saison en
d1
une rencontre fermée qui a vu les
yvelinois s'imposer 1 à 0 grâce aux
vénézuéliens ronnie mattera nous et jagr
en train dé attendait spécifiques et
mais là la cia vient frapper il a fait
un triplé et après les lui il a fait un
pas ce vol il ya marqué les bois un
match ou à l'autre vénézuélien s'est
également illustré surnom all your
francs que lopez lui des cinq recrues du
club attiré plus d'une centaine de
lancer pendant la partie
relancé en tout cas sur un monticule il
a maîtrisé vraiment beaucoup mieux que
le lanceur adverse
au niveau des stray cats il a une
dizaine de straka et donc il ya vraiment
maîtrisé son match malgré la victoire le
staff espère voir l'équipe progresser
offensivement pour atteindre les
objectifs du club une place dans les
trois premiers et une qualification en
coupe d'europe
il faut vraiment qu'on commence quand ce
calibre c'est un début de saison donc je
leur laisse le temps de s'habituer au
retour c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
non plus de revoir des lanceurs un peu
plus rapide puisqu'en pro quand saison
on n'a pas eu affaire à ce genre de
lanceur donc c'est vrai que le temps de
jeu dès qu il faut qu'ils se il faut
qu'il se règle à kuala faut qu'israël et
ça va venir
dans la deuxième rencontre de la journée
face au puc eux les y montrent un se
sont une nouvelle fois imposé de
justesse 5 à 4 prochain match le
dimanche 15 avril sur le terrain de
savigny sur orge
en attendant les couillard peuvent
savourer
du football à présent ont joué ce
week-end dans le championnat de
régionale 4 ce dimanche trap a
lourdement chuté sur le terrain de
sarcelles le score est sans appel à 5 à
0 pour les joueurs du val d'oise
cette 11e défaite de la saison peut être
lourde de conséquence trappe et 12e du
classement sur 14 équipes engagées ne
compte que deux petits points d'avancé
sur ecouen le premier relégable
la fin de saison s'annonce tendue pour
les hommes d'arnaud mbc ont joué
également dans le championnat de d1 de
district maurepas s'est imposé sans
trembler 2 à 0 contre montigny le
bretonneux ce dimanche
résultat qui permet au mur païen de
conserver la deuxième place du
classement
de son côté à guyancourt futur
adversaire de maurepas en finale de la
coupe d'asie me s'est imposé 1 à 0
contre les clayes-sous-bois et reste en
course pour le podium
dans les autres matches où ils
l'emportent 3 1 gargenville gagne contre
le chesnay 1 0 les mureaux ont étrillé
hardricourt 5 0 et le pecq s'impose
contre epône de la boxe à présent dans
ce set 8 sport est une déception dans le
championnat awb a super moyens l'élan
courtois a dit la moue madistes incliné
aux points le vendredi 30 mars à
levallois face à nadjib mohammedi à
l'unanimité des trois juges une défaite
qui pourrait priver le sportif yves
binois d'un combat pour un titre mondial
nous avons la chance de le recevoir sur
sur le plateau bonsoir a dit là bas ce
soir la première question comment avez
vous récupéré ma famille surtout parce
que vous sentez bien physiquement oui et
surtout mentalement je me sens très bien
physiquement et mentalement maintenant
je pense que
la défaite c'est pas ce qui ce qui
m'amène à arrêter voilà mes objectifs
sont toujours présents vous avez vous
avait 38 ans oui oui 38 ans du coup
cette défaite est elle justifiée
c'est d'éveiller les joies juges l'ont
donné vainqueur
oui après bon bah c'est sûr que j'étais
pas spécifié bon on ne s'est pas
spécialement je n'étais pas spécialement
au top de ma forme
ce jour là bas
voilà différents virus que j'ai pu
attraper bas c'était à saison un peu et
donc j'ai pourtant non j'ai
malheureusement j'ai j'ai accepté
maintenant j'assume j'ai accepté de
monter sur le ring du coup on a fait ce
qu'on avait à faire mais c'est vrai que
je n'étais pas spécialement le combat
qui sur lequel j'ai pu donner ce que je
devais
et donné je me suis senti mieux même sur
ma préparation que le jour du combat et
vous avez parlé avec votre promoteurs
oui de ce virus oui ben t'as dis à
gbagbo
après après le combat maintenant je
pensais pas
que j'aurais j'aurais pu être atteints à
ce point là c'est vrai que sur le coup
bas on y va à écrêter de parce que
mentalement on sait ce qu'on veut est
finalement bon voilà la tête doit être
accompagnée du corps sur ce match vous
avez été largement surclassé à votre
avis je ne sais pas quel compartiment
non merci
je pense tout simplement la solution
j'avais la solution je la connaissais la
solution je savais ce que j'avais à
faire
après c'est sûr que bas
dans l'état dans lequel j'étais quand je
suis monté sur un ring je pense que le
corps n'a pas suivi quoi alors qu'il y
avait il ya vait j'avais énormément de
réponses à à ce que je vais faire sur le
combat et vous disiez nous vous n'allez
pas arrêter votre carrière n'en avait
même demandé une revanche si votre
adversaire c'est ça c'est ça s'accepte
un peu
je pense j'attends ça va être nul ça va
ça va être ça va être vu avec le
promoteur je pense mais oui
effectivement je pense que non en
revanche pour être pour être une belle
chose je suis prêt à le faire dans les
meilleures conditions surtout vous en
avait parlé avec votre adversaire
non paris d'accord après je pense que
comme tout boxeur il accepterait situe à
lui si elle lui apporte quelque chose
c'est pas le cas je ne sais pas le
combat pourrait être organisée à quel
moment on disait vous aimez 38 ans n'ont
pas traîné non faut pas traîner c'est
sur faut pas traîner mais bon les envies
ne font pas
m'arrêteront pas du mois là je m'arrête
m'arrêtera pas où j'en suis quoi vous
avez donc toujours espoir d'être
champion du monde c'est votre objectif
numéro un l'ancienne place mondiale vous
êtes quand même redescendu au 30e rang
mondial est ce que c'est encore possible
aujourd'hui je remercie déjà monsieur
malamine koné mon promoteur de me
laisser c'est de m'avoir laissé cette
chance de pouvoir
faire une ceinture comme celle ci et je
lui fais confiance aujourd'hui comme
j'ai pu lui faire confiance au préalable
pour pouvoir récupérer mon titre
européen organisé de nouveau à
à 50 ans c'est sa rentrée réellement
dans mes projets tout ce qu'on a pu
faire en amont avec monsieur madame il
connaît donc là encore une fois je vais
lui faire confiance pour pouvoir faire
ou organiser quelque chose de génial
pour moi en tout cas vous sentez encore
frais physiquement ou way ferait
toujours vous avez encore trois à quatre
ans 50 box encore devant moi
on va peut-être pas dire ça on je dirais
simplement que j'ai encore des objectifs
voilà donc je prends encore plaisir j'ai
toujours ce plaisir et ses fameuses
objectif vous avez également de nombreux
fans en france ce sont eux qui vous
pousse on va pouvoir me pousser bien sûr
ils me poussent ils me font plaisir il
me donne de la force je les remercie
d'ailleurs il me donne de la force et
puis j'espère que je peux aussi pour
certains de randonnée quoi ce
championnat du monde c'est votre dernier
challenge gagnés ou perdus vous voulez
un championnat d'où un championnat du
monde c'est vrai que dans tous les cas
quand je suis passé boxeur professionnel
j'avais pas spécialement cet objectif là
à chaque fois j'en ai eu un on a réussi
à l'atteindre avec rothen farrugia et
puis et puis c'est lui qui m'a qui m'a
aussi appris à être assez déterminés
dans ce que je voulais donc passé
s'abattre sur ce qu'on n'avait pas mes
et les moyens pour avoir ce qu'on
souhaite
et vous raccrocherait après ce combat
si j'ai pas de tir et ici j'ai pas
d'autre objectif je raccroche oui si
j'en ai d'autres je raccrocherai pas les
prochaines semaines ça va être quoi quel
est votre programme sur les prochaines
semaines assure les prochaines fois
prochaines semaines je souhaitais déjà
dans un premier temps réellement ont
récupéré me consacrer peut-être aussi un
peu plus à ce que je ne fais peut-être
pas assez
un peu de repos et puis
on verra on discutera avec avec monsieur
malines koné de du futur merci à vous a
dit là où on m'a dit on vous souhaite le
meilleur pour la suite de votre carrière
et elle n'est pas terminée votre
carrière dans les facteurs bien on
espère que vous aurez cette revanche
contre nadjib mohammedi merci beaucoup
jusqu'à direction à présent les terrains
de rugby ont joué ce week-end en honneur
le sky rugby a réussi à valider son
maintien dans ce championnat à domicile
après une victoire 29 à 14 face à
ministère finance paris le résumé du
match les images sont signés à nicolas
d'andrea montage de romain à ospina
ce dimanche 9 avril le sky rugby joué sa
survie dans le championnat de division
honneur à domicile face à ministère
finance paris un match à enjeu qui n'a
pas tétanisé le promu dès les premières
minutes de la rencontre les saint
quentinois mettre du rythme et remporte
la première période 17 à 7
avec deux essais inscrits raconté
c'était de se faire plaisir malgré la
pression du maintien
maintenant on voit que il ya un vrai
objectif parce que l'intensité est
vraiment présente au retour des
vestiaires le ska et rugby continue sur
sa lancée les bleus réalisent un 100% au
pied en seconde période grâce à jules
auber est la faille pour l'emporter 29 à
14 au coup de sifflet final
ce collectif l'équipe l'équipe va bien
marcher devant derrière c'est bien
connecté le lancement de jeu était
propre
avec cette victoire les saint quentinois
sont assurés de terminer à la huitième
place sur dix équipes engagées avec
quatre points d'avancé sur manque limer
le premier relégable le staff se
projette déjà sur la saison prochaine
il faut pas rajouter une seule chose il
faudra rajouter plein de petites choses
pour que ça se passe bien
la fois être meilleur a physiquement
pour être meilleur que quelques joueurs
qui viennent un peu plus un peu plus
chanceux sur blessure parce qu'on a bien
chargé cette année en blessure donc donc
ça arrive mais
alors au charme a peut-être besoin de
moi de malchance là dessus et après
c'est toujours progresser c'est à dire
que là au match aller on a fait on a
fait trois victoires et et au match
retour on a fait 3 victoires + 1 nul
donc c'est mieux
le sky rugby clôturera sa saison ce
dimanche 15 avril contre vincennes à
domicile en match en retard
l'occasion de préparer déjà la saison
2018 2019
dans l'autre poule de division honneur
ce dimanche versailles s'est largement
imposé sur le terrain de chilly-mazarin
sur le score de 47 à 22 leur 13e
victoire de la saison et le troisième la
troisième de rang un résultat qui permet
aux joueurs de la cité royale d'être sur
le podium
l'un de leurs objectifs cette saison et
de ne compter que quatre petits points
de retard sur la deuxième place détenue
par bagneux le championnat est lui
toujours dominé à part sarcelles enfin
toujours en rugby mais cette fois ci
dans le championnat de fédérale 2
plaisir promu cette saison restera dans
cette division l'année prochaine les
plaisirs on est officiellement validé
leur maintien sur le terrain de domont
ce dimanche la victoire est sans appel à
54 à 7
au classement les hommes de sébastien
roncalli compte 15 points d'avancé sur
le premier relégable
arras prochain match le dimanche 22
avril sur le terrain de chartres en
athlétisme la 24e édition de la guye en
course se tenait ce dimanche au départ
et arrivée au gymnase des droits de
l'homme que la compétition était temps
réalisé par le club de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
quatre courses étaient au programme 3
pour les enfants et un tracé phare de 10
km autour des étangs de la minière plus
de 300 personnes ont pris part à ce 10
km les objectifs de la glu en course
expliqué au micro de nicolas d'ambri
c'est une fête qui portait aussi par des
parrains club d'athlétisme des gens qui
aiment tous la course à pied et donc qui
font des courses à pied et en eux
quelque part quand on fait de la course
à pied on a aussi envie de rendre et de
proposer des courses autres personnes
pour extraire aimer ce sport aux gens
c'est qu'ils se meut sur piste à présent
et plus précisément du cyclisme sur
piste handisport un yvelinois valide du
club de vélizy 78 à participer à mi mars
aux championnats du monde avec raphaël
baud juillet à l'athlète handisport
déficients visuels son nom à yann
dujarrier il est avec nous sur ce
plateau mont royal monceau michael alors
comment vous êtes vous
remis de ces championnats du monde bien
c'est bien beau tout à fait ça c'est
exactement le type de deux termes c'est
vraiment redescendre du nuage puisque
c'est une expérience que que j'ai
beaucoup apprécié et que je n'imaginais
pas un jour pouvoir pouvoir réaliser
alors comment s'est déroulée votre
compétition bien bien bien puisque d'un
long à réaliser quasiment la totalité de
nos objectifs on était là-bas pour pour
simplement battre no no no meilleur
temps que la fin des temps que nous
avions établi lors des championnats de
france début février à bourges on avait
fait une 8,0 sur le 08 sur le sur le
kilomètre et on a fait une 6 4 donc très
bien
ensuite sur le 200 m en effet 11,3 et là
on a fait dix huit cents tout rond ce
qui nous a permis de rentrer dans les
points
pour obtenir des quotas pour les jeux
paralympiques de tokyo en 2020 e
maintenant voilà on a raté la cerise sur
le gâteau qui aurait été de 2
de rentrer dans les huit premiers avec
un 19 tandems engagés sur sur ce toit de
vitesse de rentrer dans les huit
premiers pour pouvoir faire des matchs
de vitesse contre contre les grosses
grosses nations
maintenant voilà on a deux mois et demi
simplement de collaboration avec eux
avec rafael
donc c'est très très encourageant et
j'espère que demain ce sont des étapes
que l'on pourra gravir et franchir lors
dès lors des prochaines éditions
c'était votre première compétition
internationale avec un athlète
handisport est ce qui est le manque
d'expérience s'est fait ressentir
finalement sur sur la compétition non
puisque
puisque les deux vécu j'ai pas compris
sport jeu ouais mais j'ai pas commencé
le vélo la semaine dernière
donc c'est vrai que ben ça reste un
championnat du monde je veux dire on est
on est entre coureurs on connaît nos
protocole d'échauffement enfin
personnellement je connais protocole
d'échauffement
donc j'ai pas eu de stress par rapport à
par rapport à ça c'est vrai que là on se
rend compte que même par rapport à un
chapelet de master que j'ai pu que j'ai
pratiqué plusieurs
enfin les années précédentes bas on est
encore un niveau haut niveau au dessus
les organisations de certaines certaines
nations sont sont vraiment
impressionnantes
les anglais les hollandais les
américains ont vraiment un staff qui
était très différent de ce que j'ai pu
vivre j'ai jamais vécu des choses comme
comme ça c'est vraiment différent d'une
compétition valide ou pas alors que vous
m'avez permis de vivre en tant que
spectateurs n'ont cessé alors pour les
grosses structures qui sont très très
bien organisé c'est la même chose ils le
pren de la même manière il sait pour eux
c'est la même chose un titre de champion
du monde handisport ou un titre de
champion du monde élite a la même
importance j'ai vu un titre de champion
du monde pour un pour un athlète
brésilien
voilà dans le vélodrome c'était c'était
énorme quoi vraiment il y avait il y
avait quelque chose et puis en plus
alors après il ya je pense même une un
truc en plus c'est à dire que on voit
que malgré les handicaps kippel zaki
peuvent avoir les handicaps qui peuvent
avoir
eh bien ça reste de vrais athlètes et
avec des très grosses préparations et
puis et des fois c'est vrai que vous
croisez les gens dans les dans les
couloirs ou arrêt dans les couloirs du
vélodrome et vous vous demandez comment
est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir pédaler et
quand vous les voyez sur le vélo bien
sûr qu'on est chez nominatif quoi ça on
reste admiratif des efforts et des
chronos qui peuvent qu'ils peuvent
réaliser parce que ça ça reste d'oeuvre
est vrai très belles performances comme
sur l'essai les valides je crois que
dans la catégorie reine alors cette m5
le chrono enfin le champion du monde
dans cette catégorie là il fait une 01
il faut savoir que peu de temps avant
sur les chez les valides d'assez gagner
en 59 secondes alors
voilà handisport ça reste des très très
belle performance l'aller les anglais
ont fait 9 8 109 700 sur le vélodrome de
rio faut savoir que jason kenny tout
seul lors des jeux olympiques donc avec
une forme olympique
il avait fait que 9 500 dons qu'on est
aussi pareil sur du c'ur du mla même si
c'est un tandem il ya deux gars sur un
vélo on est sur les performances sont
très proches des performances des élites
ont poussé tous les athlètes à faire
comme vous à aider les athlètes
handisport oui clairement
c'est aujourd'hui ça a changé ma vision
de l'entraînement ça a changé ma vision
du
ma vision du sport tout simplement et ya
un vrai apprentissage aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que je vais déjà j'étais quand même
sur une saison qui était qui était
compliqué où je n'avais pas du tout
objectif puisque je n'allais pas
participer aux championnats du monde
masters cette année donc j'étais sur une
saison 2
transition maintenant
ben grâce à ça j'ai continué et continue
de m'entraîner comme si comme si comme
comme si j'allais j'allais faire un
autre championnat parce que un an un
objectif qui était sur plusieurs sur
plusieurs années mais mais c'est vrai
que j'encourage tout le monde à tester
et parce que ça va leur permettre de
comprendre des choses sur sur la
pratique du vélo
et puis après il ya un vrai plaisir
c'est moi quand je vois sur sur certains
efforts j'ai tout le temps l'impression
de pouvoir remettre alors qu'au bout
d'un moment ça s'arrête et le problème
du tandem c'est quand ça s'arrête là
s'arrête encore plus fort quand on est
tout seul
là on prend on prend très cher mais mais
ouais il ya eu vraiment des sensations
qui sont et qui sont super intéressante
en tout cas cette association le pistard
du loir-et-cher raphaël bogies et veut
la poursuivre avec vous sur la prochaine
année on les écoute
peut-être que yann se sous-estimer un
peu je ne sais pas il a dit qu'il serait
sûrement trop vieux mais bon l'idéal ce
serait de poursuivre jusqu'aux jeux
après qu'on n'y arrive pas mais qu'on
continue l'aventuré ensemble parce que
mon
dès qu'on change de pilotes après c'est
tout une réadaptation tout point de vue
faut qu'on se soit coordonnée et qu'on
apprenne à se connaître parfaitement
quoi est due jarrier vous avait 42 ans
rassurez-nous vous allez continuer avec
raphaël bougies et sur les géo tokyo
notamment échoué a clairement
alors je sais pas si on ira aux jo ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on mettra tout en
oeuvre pour y arriver
j'ai toujours fonctionné comme ça
aujourd'hui j'ai découvert un nouveau un
nouveau challenge qui me ment pully
vraiment
et qui me tient à coeur qui me donne
beaucoup de motivation et en effet
j'espère pouvoir aller aller jusque là
et aujourd'hui alors quand j'ai commencé
je n'y pensais pas du tout aujourd'hui
je pense que ça va être difficile d'y
aller mais je vais tout faire pour
pour réussir et c'est vrai que j'ai
et apparemment vous sous-estimez un sas
que 10 à raphaël oui non peut-être
maintenant c'est vrai que les quarante
deux ans ils sont là donc
mais bon il ya encore de la progression
c'est sûr parce que au niveau
d'entraînement je suis je m'entraîne
comme un comme vrais amateurs et si on
arrive à faire à faire quelque chose
avec la avec la fédé avec avec les
fédérations
eh bien peut-être qu'on va pouvoir un
petit peu professionnel pas pour
réaliser mais gagner encore en
préparation et donc parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui nous manque merci à vous il
ya nigeria est passé sur ce plateau on
suivra avec attention vos futurs en
performance avec votre coéquipier
handisport dans les prochaines années et
on vous souhaite d'aller aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo en 2020 vous serez
peut-être aussi aux jo de 2024 à paris
si votre condition physique le permet
avec votre partenaire handisport des
jeux parisiens qui se prépare dès à
présent à 6 ans du début des épreuves
jeudi dernier jean castex délégué
interministériel aux jo s'est rendu sur
les sites saint quentinois qui
accueilleront les athlètes la délégation
accompagnée également d'élus du
territoire s'est rendue du côté de la
colline d'elancourt qu'organisera les
épreuves de vtt au vélodrome nationale à
lille de loisirs pour étudier les futurs
plans de la piste de bmx provisoire qui
sera construite sur le secteur le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
délégation a terminé sa journée par une
visite au château de versailles qui
accueillera les épreuves de pentathlon
moderne et d'équitation
j'évoquais a précédemment les jeux
olympiques de 2024 au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines mais le site
recevra également un événement
international en septembre prochain que
la ryder cup 2018 l'équivalent de la
coupe du monde du golf pour vous
immerger a dès à présent dans ce
rendez-vous tv 78 vous propose de
découvrir chaque semaine les plus grands
souvenirs qui ont marqué l'histoire de
la compétition
aujourd'hui un philippe pilato du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
vous présente son meilleur souvenir
regardez
[Musique]
je me souviens de la ryder cup qui
s'était déroulé aucun club en irlande
là c'était plus un moment d'émotion
moment où on fait darren clarke pas
meilleurs moments de sa vie il avait
perdu sa femme je crois au mois d'août
il avait joué à l'open britannique
également mois de juillet de façon à à
pouvoir voir s'ils pouvaient rentrer
dans les points de vente dans la ryder
cup il ou pocket enfin bon plein de vie
plein d'autres choses notamment mais
comme je le disais la perte de sa femme
et gunnm snam qui le prend dans ses
capitaines ce pic dans ses choix de
capitaine est en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que darren clarke
je pense poussé par sa femme de là haut
a gagné tous ses matches et notamment
les deux doubles sur lesquels ils
avaient joué le simple également et là
c'est toute l'émotion qui est ressorti
non c'est à dire que en fait on l'image
qui est très forte c'est à la fois mes
joueurs américains qui sont venus le
voir qu'ils ont en lacets et surtout
mots ce que j'ai adoré comme image c'est
ian woosnam prenant dans ses bras darren
clarke donc il ya à peu près 30
centimètres d'écart entre les entre les
deux joueurs
bien évidemment c'est un moment émouvant
parce que moments durs pour clark mais
de voir ces deux joueurs
ces deux champions en larmes sur ce
green lamont voilà moi ça m'a réellement
retourner et je pense que la ryder
encore une fois c'est le seul événement
sur lesquels on peut wolfies qu'on peut
se retrouver à avoir des émotions
pareilles
[Musique]
un rendez vous à noter dans vos agendas
ce tournoi fait partie du paysage
sportif de plaisir depuis à 1999 et 1997
le zéro plein tournoi d'ultimate de la
ville revient ce week-end entre le
palais des sports le gymnase nicholas
l'heure nous avons pu rencontrer le
président du club 2-0 gène l'un des
organisateurs la 14e édition du tournoi
à 0 planète organisé ce week-end à
plaisir à mes côtés l'un des principaux
organisateurs mathieu gorce matthew goss
est-ce que tout est prêt à quelques
jours de l'épreuve
oui on n'attend plus que les équipes
pour démarrer le tournoi mais du côté de
l'organisation tout est en place
combien d' équipes seront présentes sur
le tour cette année donc pour la 14e
édition nous accueillons non plus huit
équipes comme auparavant mais 12 donc ça
nous permet justement de faire grandir
un petit peu l'événement et ce billet
doux à peu près de toute l'île de france
en fait on a à coeur de tenir la parité
en fête au coeur du tournoi ya la fois
des clubs qui jouent aussi en
championnat fédéral
par exemple le club de créteil le sun
l'équipe de versailles de frise et lisse
et aussi pour les tournois amicaux il ya
souvent des équipes qui se montrent de
manière éphémère juste pour le temps
d'un tournoi on a par exemple la section
ultimate de carrières sous poissy qui se
reforment juste pour l'événement on a
aussi une équipe de joueurs d'origine
sud américaine qui joue à l'ultimate en
france qui se forment pour l'événement
aussi une équipe qui joue en famille
donc plusieurs générations faire la même
équipe enfin en tout cas on a à coeur
d'accueillir à la fois des clubs mais
aussi des équipes un peu plus fun il va
y avoir du spectacle un plaisir on
espère beaucoup de points beaucoup de
belles actions et c'est souvent
spectaculaire aussi en intérieur car le
terrain est beaucoup plus court donc il
ya souvent des beaux gestes sont en
tournée
l'ultimate concrètement c'est quoi
quelles sont les règles de l'ultimate
pour quelqu'un qui ne connaîtraient
absolument pas ce sport alors en fait
c'est un sport collectif qui joue avec
un disque volant et le but est de
réceptionner un disque dans une zone
d'en-but situés de part et d'autre du
terrain dépendra le frisbee dans la main
on ne peut pas courir et la
particularité du sport c'est qu'ils les
autorités
et c'est un tournoi qui est très visuel
forcément est-ce que vous accueillez du
public également sur cet événement oui
tout à fait l'entrée est libre donc
celui toute personne qui le désirent
découvrir ce sport est la bienvenue à au
palais des sports le samedi et gymnase
nicholas faire et au palais des sports
le dimanche qu'il y aura des matches en
simultané sur les deux gymnases en
dernière question à part les pronostics
est ce que le plus de plaisir le club
zéro gêne et favori de cette édition
ah oui tout à fait on a fait une
sélection en béton donc on compte bien
se classer parmi les le plus haut des
classements après chercher le titre ça
va peut-être compliqué car il ya
beaucoup de challenge chaque année mais
oui on espère bien se classer cette
année c'est un objectif en club de
plaisir alors l'objectif principal pour
moi ce serait plutôt de très bien se
classer en championnat les tournois bien
sûr c'est un objectif sportif parce
qu'il s'agit de se roder mais je dirais
que l'objectif principal c'est de
réussir en championnat fédéral
merci beaucoup mathieu le tournoi à 0
peine 2 plaisir est organisé ce week end
c'est la fin cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]